on va parler de disco c'est le retour de
la disco roller ce samedi les chocs
d'Élancourt le club de roller hockey
organise leur traditionnel soirée disco
roller au gymnase chastagnier pour fêter
la Saint-Patrick pour en parler avec
nous Nicolas Thomas bonsoir alors vous
êtes le président des chocs dès
l'encours Nicolas Thomas a quoi faut-il
s'attendre si on a jamais participé si
on n'est jamais venu à cette soirée un
peu traditionnelle de discours roller
alors
c'est déjà à la base c'est un événement
familial donc on y vient en famille
enfants parents grand-mère qui ont vu
les
grands-mères qui font du roller notre
doyen à plus de 70 ans donc et puis
patine très bien
et puis il sera là donc si vous voulez
le rencontrer il y a pas de problème et
donc c'est un événement où les
participants donc patine en musique dans
la bonne humeur
donc dans le gymnase qui est qui est
pour l'occasion à l'aide de balustrade
et on peut on peut assimiler ça à ce
qu'on peut retrouver dans des soirées
patinoires classiques de patin à glace
ou à ce que certains ont peut-être connu
à la main jaune il y a quelques années
voilà alors quels sont les musiques
qu'on pourra entendre c'est du disco
mais est-ce que vous pouvez tout ce qui
est c'est à la fois
des styles années 80-90 évidemment mais
aussi des choses très actuelles toutes
les playlists qu'on peut entendre
sur les radios sans donner le nom de
type pop rock par exemple voilà et donc
une nouvelle fois cette année c'est sur
le thème de la Saint-Patrick est-ce que
on doit absolument venir en vert
non non c'est un code c'est un code
vestimentaire et puis
qu'on aimerait voir le plus sur le plus
le plus grand grand nombre de personnes
mais il y a aucune obligation de ce
côté-là
la déco par contre sera sur le thème de
la Saint-Patrick en vert avec des lutins
et tout ce qu'il faut et les lumières
qui vont avec alors d'année en année la
disco roller revient à Élancourt c'est
un rendez-vous vous avez des fidèles qui
attendent ça avec impatience on a des on
a nos fidèles nos adhérents
mais on a également un certain nombre de
gens de l'extérieur qu'on connaît pas et
qu'on ne voit qu'aux disco roller il y
en a deux dans l'année on en a une au
mois novembre qui est plutôt à plus de
caritatif et celle du mois de du mois de
mars qui est tout le temps calé sur la
Saint-Patrick et donc on a on a beaucoup
de gens qui nous foutent sur les réseaux
sociaux et qui nous demandent
régulièrement
la date de notre prochaine disco roller
quand on l'a pas encore communiqué
tout à fait et on échangeait justement
off vous disiez après le covid 1re
discours roller qui s'est déroulé
l'année dernière après le covid il y
avait une vraie attente des gens pour ce
rendez-vous reviennent justement à
partir du moment où les restrictions le
covid ont commencé à se lever on a eu on
a eu des demandes
en embrasser important bien plus que ce
qu'on imaginait et plusieurs mois en
avance de nous demandons
quand aura lieu cette nouvelle discover
donc ça a été un une vraie motivation
pour pour la relancer et on n'a pas été
déçu puisqu'on a eu on a eu quelque
chose comme 1150 entrées là où
habituellement on est plutôt à 110 120
d'entre elles tout à fait est-ce que ça
vous tente autour du plateau la disco
roller je crois que Céline il me semble
que vous vous faites du roller c'est une
discipline d'ailleurs qui revient de
plus en plus parce que le roller avance
aujourd'hui nos cours donc nous on a
trois activités on a l'activité de
départ qui est une activité de roller ok
qui est assimilable à du hockey sur
glace sur sur patin une activité de
course d'enduro où on va au 24 Heures du
Mans roller ce genre de chose et puis on
a une grosse activité ce qu'on a appelé
au départ initiation roller donc on
donne des cours de roller de
l'apprentissage
au départ c'était vraiment dans un but
de de d'apprendre aux gens à patiner
aujourd'hui on a des cours confirmés
avec avec des gens qui ont très très
gros niveau
et on a fait ces créneaux là sur le plan
tous les ans on est sur la partie
enfants
on est sur les attentes on ne prend plus
d'inscription environ 15 jours avant le
forum des associations donc les gens
viennent nous voir en forme des assauts
on dit bah on est désolé mais c'est sur
sur les attentes et sur les adultes
autour du 10 septembre la liste est
terminée
beaucoup quand j'étais petit est-ce que
c'est comme le vélo ça s'oublie pas le
roller ça revient vite ça revient vite
fait parce que moi aussi j'en faisais
quand j'étais petite mais
j'avais des chutes faut venir le voir
samedi vous avez aucun risque il y a pas
de voiture il y a rien ça tout est
vraiment sécurisé et vous Philippe
nizeau ça vous tenterait
de la musique je suis même capable de
faire du rôle
et bien
merci Nicolas Thomas d'avoir accepté
notre invitation si vous êtes
et la disco roller c'est ce samedi 18
mars de 17h30 à 21h30 au gymnase
chastagniers d'Élancourt le prix
d'entrée s'élève à 3 euros et attention
les rollers ne seront pas fournis il
faudra vous munir de vos propres rollers